this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's 2 2
february 2nd
of the year 22. the joint is brought to
you by manscape let's start off roses
are red violets are blue if you don't
trim your balls
nobody's gonna blow you
with valentine's day just around the
corner manscaped is here for you listen
to me
join four million men worldwide who
trust [__] manscape i got an
exclusive offer ready for this go to
manscape.com
use code diaz d-i-a-z
for 20 off and free worldwide shipping
listen you [__] let yourself go after
the holidays you got your little balls
licked
and then you're [__] strained but
guess what it's valentine and a woman
likes chocolate but a woman likes
covered chocolate [__] nuts that are
nice and [__] trim that's where the
lawnmower body trimmer comes in the best
trimmer on the market for your balls
your butt and your [__] body and then
you got the weed whacker the thing i was
using on the [__] show today it's
tremendous for your [__] nose hairs
there you go it helped prevent nicks
snags and tugs in that delicate [__]
holes and now you can pair that with
manscape's new body wash with aloe vera
and sea salt and just in time for the
romantic day of the year manscape
introduces a refined cologne and they
don't stop there now the rest of your
body can smell as good as your [__]
nut sack these formulations are vegan
cruelty free and dry free and guess what
else manscape made a lip balm so after
you trim your nut sack
they can put it on their lips and lick
your [__] balls with that new
manscape
[__] lip balm your balls and your
lady will thank you but first
go to manscape.com
put in code joey and get 20 off free
shipping that's 20
free shipping at manscape.com and use
code dsd i a z your balls are gonna
[__] thank uncle joey join cupid and
shoot an arrow with manscape you
[__] the joint is also brought to
you by
draftkings listen
the moment you've been waiting for is
finally [__] here right not this
sunday but [__] the following sunday
you got the super bowl and draftkings
the official sports betting partner is
giving you the [__] 56 to one odds on
either team that means you better fin
and you win 280 and free bets draftkings
is now live in new york meaning you can
bet from [__] the big apple buffalo
poughkeepsie and if sportsbook is in
your state yet never fear draftkings
daily fantasy is here the contest for
super bowl 56 are you ready for this
contest for you fantasy [__]
new customers can get a free shot at one
million
dollar top prize did you hear me one
million dollar top prize for first place
download the draftking sports book app
or the draftkings fantasy app now use
code joey we're gonna hook you up with
56 to one odds or you entered for a shot
at one million dollar
[__] top prize it's that easy that's
promo code joey you got to be 21 all the
minimum wage and location requirements
vary by jurisdictions see draftkings.com
sportsbook for full list of requirements
and specific responsible gaming
resources void prohibited gambling
problem call 1-800 gambler in tennessee
call tn redline at 1-800-889-9
in connecticut 888-789-7777
and in new york call 877-8 hope
that's it get your [__] together but if
you don't have a gaming prom it's time
to play for draftkings because [__]
the super bowl only comes once a year
the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen
time is money the hassle of loading up
your car and going to the post office
and waiting around online they're
[__] gone stamps.com makes it easy to
mail and ship right from the privacy of
your own home and your own computer my
wife's been using it for years she loves
it i use it save time and money with
stamps.com you can send letters and
packages for less with discounted rates
from usps ups and a lot more stamps.coms
bring the services of the us postal
service and ups shipping right to your
[__] computer whether you have a
small business or a large business they
can help you all you need is a computer
and a standard printer no special
supplies or equipment with the minutes
you're up and running pristin printing
postage for any letter any package
anywhere no traffic no line stop wasting
time going to a post office and go to
stamps.com instead with their no risk
offer use promo code joey and get a
four-week trial no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page trust me you're gonna save some
money in time type in joey j-o-e-y that
stamps.com
promo code joey let's get this [__]
party started put that lip balm on your
lips and let manscapia take you to the
next level
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday 2 2 22.
this won't happen again for a long
[__] time till 4 44 or 3 3 33 so
enjoy it it's also the happy chinese new
year it's the year of the lion or
something like that
i salute you
[__] the guy low i'm with you chinese
people
[__] the [__] guy low if you want to
know about the guy love you don't know
about the guy low you better check it
out but anyway it's a beautiful
[__] day to be alive
wednesday the second day of february we
got rid of all the [__] the [__]
resolutions you were gonna you made i'm
gonna lose 80 pounds go [__] yourself
you're still eating popsicles like
they're giving them up for free at the
[__] county [__] jail
they do give out popsicles at the county
jail they weren't bad in boulder
especially in the summertime when you're
in there sweating like [__] you know
they give you a little popsicle you have
a good time with it but who gives a [__]
it's a whole new day
we got the abx [__] uh
live resin thing today i already got
high today so if it's two o'clock i
fulfilled my obligations
the hits is short but it does the trick
especially in the mornings if you don't
want to go outside in the cold but
anyway a little something for buddha
today for the chinese people i love you
gotta rub his belly it's gonna be a good
year 2022.
i'm [__] feeling it but anyway
today's lesson what i want to talk to
you cocksucker's about i usually have a
zoom on wednesdays but you know what
obviously
listen everything is turned to [__]
zoom so i like to give it a breather
from time to time next week i'll drop
two zooms on you if you want to watch it
you do if you don't i don't know what to
tell you but today wednesday the second
it's uncle joey coming at you
[__] straight and direct
i'm doing this uh
you guys know i'm writing a book but a
buddy of mine who's the next cop
writes like a column in texas about he
was a new york city cop but he moved to
texas like everybody else but way before
the invasion he moved to texas like 10
[__] years ago
uh
he writes for a website about crime
that's what he does now he makes a
little change and we were talking about
a week ago and he was talking to me
about
that he's interviewing you know he goes
no offense some criminals i go dog i
know what the [__] i am don't feel bad
you know i was what i was it's way past
me i haven't had those uh
things in years you know
but i go uh he was writing about
criminals and uh he was interviewing
criminals and
enlightenment what was like people who
went to prison like when did you know
that you were going to get locked up or
when did you know that this was real you
know and it was really interesting i
said let me think about it give me like
a week and i'll get back to you and we
did the interview we just did it on the
phone no zoom or none
it was pretty great to get it off my
chest what i wanted to tell people for a
long [__] time you know
as a youth i grew up in harlem pretty
much i was always in [__] hall i mean
i saw some weird [__] but nothing ever
with me to be strictly honestly i got
chase one time in the bronx that was it
like in 19 who the [__] knows
i got chased like three blocks in the
bronx beside that
nothing i had never i can't tell you
what type of people i was dealing with i
knew that one
from being a youngster when i walked in
harlem i walked as if
i walked as if i was a [__] you know
don vito corleone like you have to walk
straight your shoulders you know out in
the middle of the sidewalk if you walk
close to the building that's a sign of
fear out there you're out there towards
the street and you're bouncing you know
and i was scared deep inside you know i
knew that at any time anything could
happen but over the years i learned how
to just go cop i'd eat some [__] food
and i'd get back on the lincoln tunnel
or if i drove to the bronx or whatever i
was one of those guys i went there to
get weed but at the same time i'd try
their [__] food it was like anthony
bourdain this is [__] 30 years ago i
was doing this 40 years ago we would
just pick a spot sometimes it was staten
island sometimes it was the bronx
somewhere that was close to the spot
so we could always have an excuse for
being there
if a cop pulls you over you'll at least
have to slide what are you doing here
none we came to get yankee tickets and a
slice of pizza meanwhile the [__]
coke is sitting under the car whatever
but all those years
you know when i went to colorado in 84 i
thought i was taking a break
from the high level and
you know of
of crime that i had grown up in what
high level joey
the
burglaries and the robberies and the
[__] that was going on around me like i
grew up you know 20 minutes from new
york city so you're always reading about
you know
guys that were doing drug rips you know
just
i grew up with it a lot it's not like if
you grew up
in a part of michigan you know that's
very nice she wouldn't be
exposed to all this type of [__] it's
not that i saw it but just hearing about
it goes into your psyche or whatever
so when i went to colorado i was like
well i'm stepping off this
post in fact when i went to
snowmass when i went to basalt
in 83 i slept the first three weeks
i slept the first three weeks because of
the [__] i had been going through
since my mother died this had been the
first break i had taken it was four
[__] years later
but i also slept because i didn't have
that level
of [__] in my life anymore
when i got to colorado i didn't know
nothing about nothing i knew how to
steal you know and
at the beginning i was just doing you
know people leave their windows open
[__] like that i wasn't really uh
looking i was looking to change my life
but that part of me was still there if
you're [__] stupid i'm gonna rob you
you know i'm saying if you're gonna
leave your wallet there i gotta take it
so
you know that was my first uh couple
things in
in snowmass and then i met a guy named
fred
you know and
fred was different than
anybody
that i had met here you know he was uh
after a month or two he opened up to me
and he knew about weapons and he knew
about explosives and he knew about
alarm systems and he was white and he
was smart it wasn't like a ghetto
prophet
and that was the first time i was
exposed to and i was blown the [__] away
this guy wanted to rob a bank
on christmas day with me and i was i was
i was flattered but he trusted me to rob
a bank with him but it's not what i went
to colorado for but listen to me i had
never met anybody here here you supposed
to be from new york city and i'm from
new jersey i'm supposed to be exposed to
all these gangsters and [__] like that
yeah i saw a body when i was [__]
five in harlem under a [__] piece of
4x8 but you know that that's not
what i really grew up in i wouldn't grow
up murdering people nothing like that i
heard about things but i had never met a
[__] like fred before in my life
and that was
an education and i feared fred i was
like [__]
this guy knows about everything you know
it all started with us
watching like i don't know some movie
about weapons
and me saying to him wow that's a great
gun and him going let me show you what i
got me going what the [__] you know he
moves the couch and he's got machine
guns and shotguns and
[__] grenades and i'm like what the
[__] they started telling me his stories
about vietnam so that really stuck with
me you know and then i got in trouble at
the electrician's place and he told me
how to beat up the guy i mean this guy
had it all planned i went to him in
confidence
and you know at that time i had a big
beef with my stepfather and i wanted to
kill him and he was training me
to learn how to kill how to walk and dog
i was in it
i was in it and i'm like holy [__]
how did i get involved in this i was
never involved in this [__] in new york
where i thought i would be involved in
something like this this was and i
wasn't doing anything i'm not claiming
guilt or anything he was just teaching
me how to shoot how to blow up this how
to [__] snap your neck you know it's
stupid [__]
yeah like this guy was teaching me some
out of this world [__] but again i came
to new jersey
a year later and i kept in touch with
fred and his wife and you know i became
a [__] junkie and i ended up in a
rocket ship and the whole thing
and then june of 85 i ended up going
back to colorado and you know
again i was like
you know i'm gonna go there and relax
and you know
meet some cool people and just that you
know you have the best intention when
you get on a [__] plane you know even
though your friends are telling you what
the [__] you're going out there for
you're not going to ski to a bunch of
[__] you know you heard all that [__]
from my friends but i i just knew
i wanted to be around different people
and i want to experience different
people that was even though i was
involved in all this stupidity at that
age i always wanted to get out of new
jersey i thought getting out even if you
came back
just the experience of going and coming
back is huge when you're a young man
not when you're 35 when you're like 22
shit's not working out your neighborhood
abandon ship there's 80 other thousand
[__] neighbors you could try pick one
[__] you know what i'm saying
just pick one so when i went out to
boulder in 85 i'd
i was a little bit more humbled
you know i uh
i'd been homeless i was [__] a mess
family had turned on me you know i had
turned on them so when i got back to and
i was thinking about this the other day
i've never told you this guys these
stories
when i got settled in boulder after
about a week i'm living on 10 12 14th
street
and i'm like i gotta cop some [__]
wheat you know so i didn't know where to
go i asked a couple people on my block
like a couple of the college girls we
don't smoke weed okay
so i you know i asked somebody at the
gym they didn't know you know i was
training downstairs
in boulder but they used to be a
downstairs gym on the hill god knows
what happened to them
so i went i asked a few people they told
me to go to pearl street more it's like
an outdoor mall it's what you go to
boulder for a [__] tremendous place
you know
and it was packed it was july of 85 it
was [__] packed down there
people all over the place and you know
unless you're a [__] [__]
you spot the drug dealers right away
they're right on the [__] thing
they're hippies they're playing bongos
you know boulder's a complete you know
in the city it's like black dudes
shooting dice and colombians listening
to salsa music you know or [__]
dominicans you just pull over or you can
tap
nah in boulder it's a bunch of [__]
it's a [__] bunch of hippies without
their shoes on playing congas this oh my
god it's tremendous they're playing
hacky sack they're [__] smoking
rolled cigarettes you could smell the
armpit with the patchogue and i'll never
forget going up to one of the guys and
going how you doing man my name is joey
i'm not a cop i was
85 i was 22 years old you know and i'm
like hey man i need some [__] reefer
and we started talking and one thing led
to another
and i'll never forget this [__] they
were like nah you got to talk to that
guy if you want weed he'll get it for
you
and it was a guy you know i was looking
at him from behind he had short hair
a little scruffy you know a t-shirt like
sweatpants but he had something on i
can't really
he looked baggy for some reason
and i remember going up to him and going
hey man your name is whatever
he was supposed to be like a street
shaman or one of those [__] guys
so i never forget he turned around and
he rattled me his eyes were like [__]
light blue
and his skin looked like somebody threw
acid at it holy [__] i'm like
what the [__] is this so
razz rom
one of those [__] names you know
and he had a bunch of young girls with
him and [__] like if he was 30 something
may i i was 22.
he had girls that were my age and a
little younger like a bunch of 18 year
old runaways dirty chicks
you know it was like a charles manson
type [__] deal and we started talking
i told him i want some weed he goes can
you wait 15 minutes you're sure you're
not the cop i swear to god we start
talking about new york city or jersey
and within 20 minutes i had the [__]
weed and it was good whatever i went
home and smoked and about three days
later i was looking for more weed and i
came down looking for ram or rod or
whatever his [__] name was and he was
there again and we started talking and
he had some other buddies there and in
that same encounter i met the dude fred
don't do it that fred when we were in
front of the fox theater and the guy was
gonna jump
so i
some dude was going to jump me and
frederik roses whatever it was called
eating [__] chicken they had
rotisserie chicken we had just met and
also some guy's like i'm gonna jump and
also i see a friend looking around
fred's wiping his mouth jump jump you
[__] punk i went to vietnam and all
this [__] i'm like oh my god but i met
fred through rom down there
like it was like a sunday beautiful day
out i go down there looking for whatever
his name is and it's he introduces me to
his buddy fred and we all start talking
a bunch of young guys and i walk back
and fred follows me
he goes hey man you're an interesting
guy you're from jersey
i got a brother who lives in connecticut
you know we started talking and one
thing led to another thing goes listen
i know a lady who's got better weed than
[__] rum over here
and i go when he goes up on the hill so
he goes i go she sells eights quarters
he goes she sells twenties and eight all
right take me up there
so what a coincidence if i lived at 10
12 14 street
this woman lived at 10 14
14 street she lived right in the bill in
the house next door only she lived in
the basement i'll never forget him
walking me downstairs
knocking on the door she answers the
door she's got to be like 49. she look
like a [__] frog
ugliest woman in the world no shoes on
dirty feet hippie chick
but very cool she welcomed me into a
home she told me to sit down her
boyfriend came out this lady looked like
a truck hitter and then picked her up
and a bus hit her after that but who am
i to judge i ain't no [__] i ain't no
mel gibson myself you know what i'm
saying so
i [__]
a boyfriend comes out of the bathroom
it's like a
pseudo studio a boyfriend comes out of
the bathroom and this guy
is a [__] model
he's beautiful he's got long black cat
blonde hair he looks like the dude from
sons of anarchy only a little shorter
and he's a [__] boyfriend but he's
like a [__] like a book this guy
he put his glasses on i'm like oh this
guy's really good looking he's got
[__] glasses on
this guy was a [__] nerd he knew
about everything
and we started talking went there she
was from
illinois
and he was from west virginia i still
remember that and there's more to this
[__] story and
we start [__] talking one thing leads
to another she asked me where i lived
next door boom she sells me a [__]
eight or a quarter whatever
and now you know i would go over there
to buy weed and hang out with them at
night you know and little things happen
you know fred kept going by
but then after a few weeks she told me
she goes dude you hang out with fred
he's a stone cold [__] killer i'm
like fred
i go no he's a [__] he was in vietnam
but
he was an emt she goes oh no no i'm
talking to you about the other guy his
friend roz or rod
he goes that dude
is a straight up [__] killer
like don't really put your trust in that
dude and i'm like what are you talking
about she started
you know i don't want to repeat out of
line here but she started rattling off
all these places where this guy killed
people and [__] like he was under
investigation for killing somebody at
the time
in front of a bar in one of those
boulder towns not like lafayette or
lewisville but one of those other ones
that are more secluded i forget the name
of the bar and i forget the name of the
[__] place this guy was obviously the
real deal you know he killed people in
[__] vietnam that acid that i thought
was on his face uh uh it was agent
orange
they had shot it right at this
[__] like he had all this and i
hate to touch myself and show you i mean
my skin ain't the best either
but he had all this [__] covered on both
sides
this dude was a workhorse and i remember
leaving there and finally seeing fred
and going fred come here this [__]
guy i'm buying weed from what's this
[__] that whatever eugenia that was her
name eugene or something like that
and uh they're talking about this like
this guy is a [__] maniac
there's a couple people been missing
since he came to boulder like this is
[__] crazy you know
so i was like it's good to [__] know
you know and i saw him after that a few
times but to be honest i wasn't ready
for all that
i was not ready for all that i had my
hands full with fred
fred had become my [__] buddy that
summer all of july i bummed around with
fred and for years
i didn't know where he lived i know he
lived by chautauqua park and those
little condos in the back not condos
they're like little houses in the back
but i never visited him he never gave me
a reason to visit him he would always
walk to my house from chautauqua park
and we'd start our day whatever i go to
the gym he'd go down a pearl street get
some weed i'd buy some [__] hot dogs
and musters last stand you know he was
my dog and then he found that i was
doing the credit cards when i got the
credit cards back he was my [__]
assistant you know we went out and
banged out all these [__] credit
cards but to rush the [__] story like
i knew fred for all those years
i left san francisco i left l uh
colorado boulder
maybe
seven weeks after i left fred and i
didn't get a chance to say goodbye to
him but i told you jenna the lady next
door that i was leaving to san francisco
that the cops were on my trail
so i never really kept in touch with
fred but when i got back in november of
i went looking for fred and i found them
within [__] 10 minutes
down at eugenia's and we hit it right
the [__] off and that's when i started
seeing
who fred really was so
i was telling this detective buddy of
mine that it was weird that i had grown
up in new york you guys are saying like
where the [__] is he going with this
it's so weird
who you're gonna meet and who you think
you're gonna meet who the [__] you think
you're dealing with
you know when i left jersey and went to
colorado i had an awakening
when i went to san francisco
i was
way out of my [__] league
you know when i tell you guys i spent
those eight weeks in san francisco those
six weeks in san francisco i was living
like one of those kids on the [__]
wire i was out there on the street it
was either you know i wasn't slinging
crack or heroin
my thing was weed
travelers checks buying travelers checks
buying stolen stuff that was my stuff
out in the street you know i shared it
with the people like if i put something
on the corner everybody got a taste even
if i just walked over 50 bucks i gave
everybody else a taste you learn about
that type of world but in san francisco
when i saw the white dude fighting the
black dude with a sword and a two by
four
i realized i was out of my [__]
element on hate ashbury that was when i
when you go into the [__] tenderloin
in 85
you know when i got off the bus i don't
know forget this you get off the bus you
land in san francisco
and there are these buses and they take
you to wherever that you know when they
say downtown they don't tell you it's
the [__] you know
that neighborhood that's the worst
neighborhood in the country it is [__]
now they're going nuts up there in san
francisco but when you get to that bus
station and you get off in that that
town whatever downtown
you're in the middle of that
nightmare and you see people on the
floor stabbed and [__] first time i saw
a [__] on the floor stabbed
i'm 21 years i don't need to see this
[__]
this was crazy i saw another guy with a
knife in his stomach with the knife
still in there the dude moved it up and
you could see [__] coming out he was in
front of original joys right there on
the [__] tenderloin
and people were walking past them listen
in new york city i've seen people you
know bleeding and people walking past
them but a knife in the side and there's
a puddle of blood and the blood is black
that's [__] real and scary
was i scared [__] yeah i was scared i
didn't have a weapon then
i was in san francisco i had like a
knife or something like that like one of
those barbecue knives that has the
toothpick and the bottle opener who are
you going to stab with that somebody
will take that and stick that cork right
up my [__] ass you know you're down
there hand to hand come and thank god to
this day nothing happened to me down
there but then i went back to boulder
and this is where the story gets [__]
tricky
you know
you all see these gangsters on tv and
all this [__]
i don't know i don't know half the time
and i was meeting all these guys back
here in 84 and all these drug dealers
and i was obviously burning them and
getting away with it you know when i
obviously went
and robbed the jewelry store in
september of 82 which we're coming on
the 40th anniversary i'm gonna make a
videotape of me running around the video
store and how long are the jewelry store
and see how long it'll take me for the
one year anniversary september 15th or
september 22nd 1982 but even then i
remember those guys coming to talk to me
and saying they want the jewelry they're
going to give me ten thousand dollars it
was a friend of a family friend that was
supposed to be in the mafia and i was
like nah dawg i never thought i was
gonna make it out of that i thought they
were going to come back and kill me what
they did was put the cops to squeeze me
that's a complete different squeeze but
they never did nothing
there was only two people who i saw that
i was definitely [__] scared of when
i crossed my godfather
i mean this [__] put baptism he
put the bible he put everything on the
side this dude was coming for me
was i scared i was a little bit scared
but he got more of my attention
like i was 21 years old and i burned my
stepfather my
godfather and this guy was not stopping
till he put a bullet in me
that does something to you it gives you
a certain type of fear that gives you a
certain type of reality in my world when
i escaped that i thought i was out of it
but when i went to the west coast you
know you always think that
this is the worst place you live in
until you go to those places and go
what the [__] am i involved in and even
then guys i was doing stupid petty
[__] on the [__] street i wasn't
doing nothing
you know to go away to i wasn't doing no
[__] burns
you gotta do this from time to time i
felt a little hairy there
and [__] it's manscape day so
you got the [__] weed whacker this
trims everything tremendous see
here's how you do it
nice and easy
huh who's better than uncle joey
so
here i am and i'm thinking you know
you're thinking that you're in the worst
place you came from the baddest
gangsters i tell you what when i went
out there in the real world i could look
you [__] in the face and i was
running in new york in the late 70s
early 80s new york wasn't [__]
to what i was about to see out there
that's crazy how you always think you
know new york brooklyn
it was nothing compared to what i saw
out there in the real world i.e
colorado listen
san francisco oakland
there's supposed to be some bad
[__] living there
seattle all that [__]
there's supposed to be some bad
[__] living there you expect
that
but when you go to the mountains of
colorado
and there's bad [__] there
that's where you go what the [__]
so what i'm trying to tell you is that i
went to the tenderloin
i went to [__] boulder
i was at all these places where well
when i went to bold i didn't anticipate
what i saw but
even bolder when i was there the first
time
i was hearing things
that were really surprising me for a
small [__] community how it was
i was hearing about drug deals and
packages i mean i didn't know any of
these people
but the biggest thing that happened in
boulder
that led to other things i didn't know
at the time i didn't know these people
were
was they found
i think like 10 pounds of coke
you guys could look it up in a bus
station in boulder 8 kilos 8.6 i forget
what it was they found in a locker and
boulder
that changed everything i remember that
happening i remember going [__]
both had eight kilos in a [__] train
station
you know i just i was here in union city
and in new york and harlem that's where
the bulk of the coke was i had no idea
he was emboldened i wouldn't learn until
later on whose coke that was and what
that
bust led to like two years [__] later
so
i'm in san francisco doing what the [__]
i'm doing i'm watching these people
bleed to death
i'm watching this [__] uh guy that's
[__] two gay guys and he's making
them sell drugs this is all like you
know
nothing compared to what i was gonna say
like so when i went back to boulder
in
october of 86 you know i went i got a
job washing cars
drying off cars getting tips you know i
was still shell shocked
from my uh dealings in [__] san
francisco and [__]
or my dealings in uh
yeah in san francisco so when i went
what's that
oh [__] when i went to boulder and uh
back in 86 i didn't know you know i was
going back to the go on the up and up
that's it i had run the muck
i had run amuck and [__] in san
francisco i had run amok in boulder and
now i was back
so i laid low
i didn't bother anybody i wasn't
involved in anything but then like by
april
i started seeing weird [__] in the paper
like this
cuban kid was at the university of
boulder and they found this car
and he was bludgeoned to death there was
blood everywhere but they never found
the body
and i'm like really this [__] happens in
boulder up on the hill
and then there was this other guy that
[__]
they busted into his apartment and he
jumped out the balcony and he broke
broke both legs and they took like
you know four pounds of coke from him
and the
cops were looking for the coke and then
a kid that i worked with that his father
owned
not able's pizza he would own the other
chain
rails uh
roman or some pizza was on
it was down in south boulder he had
maybe three pizza joints not bad they
were all sucked but he was a nice kid
his family
sold pizza he was a really nice kid he
wanted to get away from the family
business
and he got a job with me at bill crouch
subaru before i got in trouble with the
kidnapping
and one night he was just he went home
he got out of work at nine
and uh
he went home to take his dog out for a
walk
and he lived across he lived on 30th
close to baseline by albertson's there
and he crossed the street there was an
abandoned lot in there by albertsons
tons of grass there you know and he'd
let his dog off the leash and
you know he's just a straight this guy
didn't get high i think he just drank
good good looking kid i forget what his
name is i'm sorry
and uh 10 minutes there he's looking at
his dog his dog is like [__]
shaking his head at something
he goes over to see what it is and it's
a [__] briefcase
it's one of those business cases not the
ch that you open up it's one of the ones
that you open up this way
and there was two [__] packages of
blow and a bunch of cash
so he's a white kid he doesn't know
anything about this
i know he should have left it there but
he picked it up and he started walking
back to his thing with it he you know he
wanted to call the cops he wanted to do
something he was panicking he didn't
know what the [__] to do i mean i mean i
i would have shot the dog and ran the
other way but
you know
but no witnesses but he went
with the [__] dog and next thing you
know before he hit his house
cars started [__] coming up from
everywhere
people would chase them they took him
down they took his dog from him he said
they took him down the [__] floor
took the bag from him and they all you
know was the feds it was the feds
they're like dea whatever they took them
down they handcuffed them and they set
up a [__] tent right there
to test the coke and to count the money
because it was [__] surreal this kid
was [__] a pickle he spent the night
in jail his father had to get him on the
morning on personal reconnaissance they
realized it wasn't his and there was a
misunderstanding and what he came down
to was the cops were chasing somebody in
boulder
and this guy threw the bag out by 29th
and baseline and they went back
and they were waiting on him to come
back and get it so
again when i hear this [__] i'm like
there's some [__] and mold i gotta tap
into
there's some creepy [__] going on here
in boulder
and you know i thought this was like a
nickel bag type of city this ain't no
nickelback type of [__] city
these people are [__] making it
happen here
and that's when pretty much i got myself
in trouble listen when i i was thinking
about the snowmass club
when i was talking to this cop we spoke
about the snowmass club he said on my
podcast
that he had heard that i was a volunteer
fireman and [__] like that i'm like no
i couldn't climb up a [__] ladder if
you paid me one thing i was petrified of
was ladders
but i was coming i was going from i mean
this is when i got myself a little
higher
you know like i said guys
you don't know you're in it till it's
too [__] late
and you don't know you're in it until
you're in it like at one point you're
sitting there
you're on a plane you got 12 ounces of
coke on you and there's a [__] guy
next to you that you know is a cop and
the rest of the flight you're just
praying that
you just make it and get in the [__]
car and you swear to god that if this
gets through it you'll never do it again
and that's the life i was living i was
so deep in the cocaine addiction
so deep in that [__] miami vice
make-believe world that listen it got me
i'm not gonna sit here and tell you it
didn't
with all that [__] going into me that's
what i wanted to be i had no
there was no comedian in my future there
was no
[__] student there was nothing i just
wanted to do blow and get the party
started nothing wrong with that but it
doesn't work forever you know what i'm
saying
so that was [__] surreal
you know i was looking
that's when i knew man this was i was
doing
i was involved in so many [__] things
you know from
trading cops coke for guns they
picked up
that's not who the [__] i am i must have
done that 10 times with the same [__]
cop gotten he's not a cop anymore he's
somewhere in jersey
planting tomatoes or something like that
but it was just so weird the people i
was involved in but the day they came
and knocked on my door a dear friend of
mine
and he's like hey man you owe me some
money
i haven't you know said anything to you
about it i know you're going through
your struggles but
here's a way you could pay me back and
make a ton of loot
instead of going to jersey
to uh
to get coke and put yourself through all
that
we got a big time connection here for
you and you know me dog i was a a
[__] idiot from new york city jersey
i'm thinking i could cover the spread
and i'm like yeah i'll meet with them
i'll pack a gun and [__] and i'll go
down there i thought it was an episode
of miami vice and guys
it did become an episode of miami vice
i met this guy my friend we drove to
like woody creek somewhere
you know and then we got out of the car
we met another guy
and they're like do you mind if you put
a hood on your head i'm like
what the [__] is going on
and i put my [__] hood on and we
drove to this place and when i got there
[Music]
i walked into a warehouse and they took
my hood off but the two dudes i was
talking to them that had their hoods on
you don't need this in your life
and i was [__] the pickle i thought
they were gonna [__] kill me
but they did make me a good coke deal or
whatever and i agreed to it
but then a week later the guy says to me
listen they don't hand it to you
you have to become a member of the
snowmass club and i'm like are you
[__] [__]
and they're like yeah you call the
number you tell them you're ready you go
to the snowmass club you give the
chicken the reception your money
and you go work out like nothing
happened when you get back to your
locker there'll be a package in your
locker waiting for you i was like oh my
[__] god
what the [__] am i in
and right away guys you know me dog i
thought it was i'm into
simple hand-to-hand combat i give you a
package you give me the cash but no
this was and i
if you think i was comfortable with
giving some [__] girl
you know eight thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars i really [__] wasn't
but that's what they wanted to do but
for me to do that i had to become a
volunteer fireman
and that's when you got to sit back and
go joey
that's when i stopped listening to you
how the [__] did you become a fireman i
didn't that's what i'm trying to tell
you
they made me train and [__] i told them
some story at that time guys i was
strong i was tough but i was not down
with heights
i was not down with heights i had a job
in philadelphia glassboro my buddy got
me that i had a put 90 pound roll on
roofs that's all you did all [__] day
that's how strong i was 18
17 i would come down with kurt delorenzo
god rest his soul and he got me a job
they give you a 75 flat a day
i would stab a [__] 1983
[__] 82 the winter of 82 i would stab
you for 75 a day
i would [__] come down here on a
monday tuesday wednesday make two and a
quarter and take that party back up to
north jersey and smoke coke and share
with my friends but we went up a ladder
but it wasn't that bad of a ladder and i
got used to it you know it was like you
went up the ladder with the roll on and
[__] like that you know hold on one
second
i brought that little nugget over here
again i'm telling you
oh there we go see you sometimes you got
to take the hair out like a violin
you hear it
you hear that that's that's [__] the
weed whack a [__] sucker
so
like they made me [__] run
they made me carry like a dummy up a lot
i was [__] my pants but thank god it
was just like two floors
and they were like to get to the next
level you got to go yeah we'll burn that
bridge when we get to it because they
were building
the battleship up in that in snowmass
village they were building this big
building so they wanted you to prepare
you when you had to go for a fire there
everything in snowmass village is two
floors maybe three floors tops
so i could handle it but i was scared of
big heights so i got the training over
with
guys i did it for maybe
the training was like three weeks i did
it for maybe
six weeks and i'm like one night they
contacted me for a [__] fire
i was snorting up a storm with my
girlfriend at the time
my ex-wife
and uh i'm never forget that my [__]
walkie-talkie went off and i just turned
that [__] off like the bodyguard
narcos when the cops are coming i just
turned that [__] off they even
came to my house
and [__] we're like beeping the horn
with like a pseudo fire truck
and i'm like if you think i'm going to a
[__] dumpster to turn it off at five
in the morning with 80 [__] idiots
because they were all gung-ho about it i
just stopped showing up and then one day
they sent me a letter you're getting
thrown out that means you lose your
membership at the [__]
snowmass club but by that time it was
too late i was already down 40 g's to
these [__] and they were
threatening to do a bunch of [__] guys
they were like we're gonna come to your
house and start taking [__] first and
then we're gonna come again if you don't
have money we're gonna start taking it
out on you and i'm like really
obviously you don't know much about me
they didn't even get to my house one
time i told them i'd have the money by
sunday they believed me like [__]
[__] after six months to tell them
and but when they came back
i was already going [__]
south to boulder colorado they were i
remember i have a friend up there mike
roebuck
we were in touch he didn't nobody else
knew that me and him were in touch
and we were laughing our asses off he's
like dog they all went to your house
they ended up taking a lamp who takes a
[__] 10 lamp you know they're
probably still up there waiting for the
money [__]
1986 holy [__]
wow
that's 14 plus 22.
that's 32
holy [__] that was 36 years ago
yeah there's probably two of those guys
and here's the funny thing when i got
separated at 90 yeah october 91 i wanted
to go for a ride
and i took the car and i went up the
[__] snowmass i went to i went to
aspen first and on the way back i
stopped through [__] snowmass
and i go let me go to the stewpot and
get some [__] stew i went up there i
got some stew on the way back to my car
who do i bump into
the guy who turned me on for that that
after i burnt them they put the dead on
him
and i'll never forget i just went up to
him gave him a hug he wasn't heavy the
people he was with was heavies
i give one up to him gave him a hug
and he's like after a few minutes like
where do you live boulder i heard you
were in boulder
and he's like what happened what have
happened to that money and i go dog
it was a long time ago i really thought
he was going to haul off and punch me
i really thought they were going to
follow me to my car and beat me up
nothing
i walked back to my car
and nothing happened
i made another snowmass
next thing i was in glenwood springs and
next you know i never heard from them
again
am i proud of that story [__] no but dog
you don't know
the animal you're dealing with
i want you guys from my stories
to always [__] know the animal you're
dealing with i came close to getting
stabbed a couple times but i swear to
god in all my history all that [__] you
watch on tv and the movies
that's straight up [__]
that wire when you watch the wire that
street living that was
i was close to that in san francisco
not in that circle there was like one of
those neighborhoods
maybe a mile away and one of the guys i
hung out from there
bamboozy cuban dude used to get his
drugs up there and dog that was not a
good [__] name but it was they were
killing people there once a [__] week
i was never involved in that [__] but
to get back to that
eight kilos that were in bold at that
time in that locker
they belong to a man named steven
graybau
steven graybau
was a [__] genius yeah he's dead they
blew him up in a jeep but let me tell
you something when it came to
distribution they did he was lifting
weights december
12th or something like that in 1984
or december 31 one of those [__]
dates it was during the holidays
every night when he'd work out before he
went out to the town of aspen
he would tip the guy 20 bucks in the gym
to go out there and start the car from
this night the kid wasn't there he went
out and started the car himself and a
[__] they put a metal bomb under his
jeep well people didn't know i said a
metal bomb they put a bomb under his
jeep
what people didn't know was that they
were in that year of jeep 84 or 83
they put a special
metal steel on the thing it was like the
story
in a
casino at the end with that [__] dude
how we go you know the nero's character
that that year they the same thing
happened with the jeep that's why he
didn't blow up
but a piece of the [__] bomb went
straight in his ass like around his ass
and he bled to that that's what he died
of he didn't blow up even though the
jeep blew the [__] up and it didn't blow
up either it's like the bottom went boom
because the metal was there so the
bottom cashed out the other side got
burnt but he made it to the hospital and
everything he was alive he died from the
internal bleeding so
that coke and the dudes hours that came
up after
grabo got blown up with the people i was
dealing with
they could have put a [__] car bomb
in me too lucky they didn't well i
wouldn't be here to tell you
[__] the story of life and you
know it's just so weird that
i always thought the baddest
[__] i grew up were in jersey
boy was i [__] wrong
there was a whole big out [__] there
was a big wide world out there
and
when i got to colorado and san francisco
that's why i got to see it but the
biggest surprise ever was in those
mountains of [__] colorado
and again i didn't know what fred was
about like my buddy fred that i keep
mentioning from boulder
i didn't really know what fred was about
until i moved back to boulder
and i got out of jail
and
i was married you know there was a time
i didn't see fred i would see fred like
maybe twice a year
i didn't know if he had moved or not
after i got separated
and got into comedy and stuff was when i
started swinging with fred again
i kept in touch with him
i gave him a few bucks when he needed it
because he was a vet he would get a
check at the beginning of the month
we would smoke pot i'd give him some pop
we'd go sell pop we'd go bipod
if i wanted a shoplift i got into
shoplifting all those years i'd have
fred come with me and i'd throw him
[__] 100 bucks so he can make a
living but it wasn't
until i got to my divorce and he saw the
pain i was going through
that one day i called i actually go fred
where do you [__] live i don't know
what happened and i drove or walked to
his house and i remember when i walked
in there i always thought fred was a
[__] medic
for some reason you know like when you
think that or something like i was
listening
to the studio 54 radio the other day and
uh
there was a couple on there it was my
favorite [__] episode of all time
they repeated it's a podcast they have
on sunday nights and they said they went
to studio like three four years in a row
and one night after four years liza
minnelli asked her
what publicity company do you work for
and she's like i'm not a publicist i'm a
dentist and she goes why did i think you
were a publicist yeah i don't know same
[__] thing
for some reason i thought fred was a
medic
but when i went to his house
i started looking on those walls
and i saw metal
after metal
after metal then i started seeing
pictures of him
with [__]
you know bodies on the floor and
blankets on top of him and
and i go fred what's this and he started
telling me about this whole [__]
thing he had belonged to
which was some ops and they came in
after the marines and threw cards on the
body like apocalypse now and they shot
villages and it was like it was like a
joint cia
army thing and he he was in the army but
not really he was killing people for
these other people and i was blown the
[__] away
here this guy that i had been total
friends with was a master of killing
he started describing to me all the
methods
he had of killing people and what they
did in vietnam and gases and bombs and
switches and i was like what the [__]
are you talking about what happened to
my crazy [__] fred i mean he just won
a tangent
and a few weeks later was when he came
to me he's like listen man i don't like
seeing you
upset like this he goes i've known you
forever
you know this is 1991 92
93 i knew fred since 85
me and fred were partners in crime you
know he was way older than me but i
didn't give a [__] he was cool as [__]
and i loved him to death
but this is the first time i got to see
fred from a different angle and he told
me one day he goes if you want to kill
your ex-wife and a [__] boyfriend i'm
like what are you talking about
you know people come up to you and offer
you an attorney they offer you a dinner
they offer you [__] like that
yeah nobody comes to you and offers you
a [__] a murder like if you want to
kill him i'll help you i got the way to
do it
we won't i mean he had
guys it was it was scary
you know when somebody comes to you and
you think they're crazy but they're
[__] not
like he was telling me [__] that was off
the chains
of how to dispose of people
burn their bodies throw acid on them i
mean this guy had a thousand ways
and in his world you had to eliminate
the bones
you know you had i mean it was [__]
crazy i mean fred how do you know about
all this [__]
and then you know i got a little bit
more desperate
and i actually told him i said it's time
for us to [__] hatch this plot out
and he's like this we're gonna do it
we're gonna [__] put a guy i'm gonna
this guy wanted to
set up like a fake detour
like a fake [__] detour and get an
orange jacket and detour my ex-wife into
[__]
this side street with killer there and
then all we putting we [__] put that
stuff on her face to knock her out like
the iceman cyanide whatever the [__]
they do and then we're gonna take her to
pass chautauqua and these weeds up there
up in the mountains nobody goes up there
just hunters during hunting season or
some [__] and he goes we'll tie him up
we'll [__] sit him down we'll put
weights on their legs and we'll [__]
rub maple syrup on them and i'm like
fred
are you [__] serious and he's like oh
i've done this before and right away
dawg
the hair's on my neck stood up i didn't
need to know that [__] i thought he
killed people hand to hand you know he
shot arrows like rambo in vietnam [__]
like that i had no i didn't have guys i
don't ask
it's not my business i i like fred but
when he told me that he had done this
before guys
i think that was like
may of 95.
and i've never discussed this with
anybody
the other part of the reason why i leave
boulder
was because of that
it was just too [__] real
you know there's one thing to say i hope
this person dies or this person gets in
a car accident when somebody comes to
you and they're telling you that they
can help you
kill them and you actually trust this
[__] because between me and you
i trusted fred like i knew him all my
life
fred was a man's man he was one of those
real dudes
that you meet uh every [__] 10 years
that
you know you don't expect to meet people
like this because they have no
responsibilities
they have no families you know that's
the guy you call when you want to go to
war
that's the guy you call when you have a
beef with somebody and you know it's not
going to end peacefully it's going to
end with
somebody going to a hospital or better
yet somebody [__] dying and that was
my reality
and i couldn't take that that was not
gonna happen you know and every time i
saw fred
it was always like this is a good
weekend to kill him it's gonna rain it's
a good weekend to kill them it's going
to be sunny it's a good weekend to kill
them and they just got and i didn't
listen
you know then i had a funny i had a
weird feeling about my wife but then i'm
very happy i didn't do anything extreme
this was not worth murdering somebody
this was just a situation of getting
your priorities in order when something
like that happens as a matter of fact
tomorrow is my uh
my first daughter's birthday
32 years old as a matter of fact today
is 32 years ago today i got let out of
the halfway house
for the final [__] time
and the next day i had the kid then
you guys know the [__] story but
i just wanted to cover today
you know the people that you deal with
now
sometimes you don't know anything about
these [__] thank god we did a
podcast today we didn't talk about
covert we didn't talk about the
guidelines
misinformation
because this is getting [__] old now
so it's like i was telling somebody at
the gym you want to bury this anybody
ever see the movie coco
you know whatever it is i was going to
say the pollock movie though do its name
but it's not disney it's the other
company
pixar pixar poll lock no offense no
disrespect to my polish family out there
uh you know coco's about a [__] uh
a guy a spirit a singer whatever the
[__] he was
that he just wanted to be remembered you
ever think about that he just want to be
remembered and that's what that's what
you do when i put my mother's picture up
i keep her spirit alive when i put
jimmy page's picture up or roberto
clemente
i'm keeping their spirit alive that's
what you want to do every time i go to a
dinner
with people and it's not coming from me
10 seconds into the dinner there's an
hour discussion of covert how we're
going to get rid of this thing today at
the gym i was sitting as a great guy
came in with a mask on and i was [__]
with him like oh [__] sucker take the
mask off the numbers were under 2000 and
he looked at me because you're right
he goes my wife [__] your wife where's
your wife is she at the gym now she's at
home watching maury povich or some [__]
you're the one that's here with us but
the bottom line is this guys
we're done
we're done you're done i know you're
done i'm [__] done with this [__] so
the only way to conquer this [__] now
finally is to stop talking about it stop
paying attention to it and live your
[__] life i'm done with this [__] i
got it i lived i'm very lucky i'm sorry
for anybody who lost anybody on facetime
um goodbye you know
[__]
death by face time whatever the [__] it
was
but what i'm trying to say is you want
to kill this thing once and for all
stop talking about it
it's over
it's february 2nd of 2022
we're on to a new leaf you had it
it's over that's it we're going to take
the mask off for kids of school pretty
soon and we're going to move on and
you're going to be stronger that's all
you control for right now whatever the
news says or people around you say shut
the [__] up the news go on it turn it
the [__] off you know what i'm saying
there's a lot of [__] going on right now
but the most important thing is that
you're taking care of yourself your
mental health you know guys i had my
[__] issues i'm back [__]
i'm scratching my balls and sniffing my
fingers and wiping my ass with this
whole situation because i'm ready to
move the [__] on you know i'm saying
that was the past one to the [__]
future light the [__] mask on fire
stop talking about it and let's move on
with our [__] lives i love your
[__] with all my heart and do not
forget
yesterday we released
white truffle
and i think today we released a new
coco i may be wrong i'm sorry i don't
have anything to show you
but it's out if you go to uh
i'll tell you right now [__]
this is how i'm gonna do for you and i'm
sorry i didn't do the research last
night
because i was a little busy
but i'll give it to you now because i
love you [__] okay
uh
green wolf dispensary and elevate
dispensary are dropping all three
strains next week
i don't know where green wolf is
dispensary and i don't know what elevate
dispensary is
but they're dropping all three strains
i'm very sorry for being unprofessional
and not having this info for you but
i'll be better by monday i'll put up a
video for what am i looking at the
microphone for i gotta be looking at you
[__] that's how [__] i'm
getting guys
uh
uh i'll have more info for you
listen i've smoked a white truffle
before it's tremendous and they
cured it and i mean listen guys it was
[__] great it is stony as [__] it's
like 35 percent when you put in your
grinder you take the [__] keith thing
off and the keefe is all over that
[__] so listen
uh kim condom is stopping by the ice
cream she stopped by yesterday and
picked up a little sample bag i'm going
to jump on her podcast and talk to her
podcast
the king condom the shank i forget what
it's called with sarah weinstock and
kim connor i'm doing that podcast
obviously we can't get no zoom guest
here i'm trying looking
we try to get this done by three o'clock
because my daughter comes home at three
i don't wanna
to hear me down here going the [__] off
if you see me doing a podcast i'm being
a little [__] quiet it's because
there's people upstairs i don't like
[__] going off when there's people
upstairs so i got to do my podcast from
eleven to three
three o'clock is 12 o'clock in [__]
l.a people are still [__] getting out
of bed
you know thinking of you know
thinking of a song to write for a dead
[__] celebrity or whatever the [__]
they're doing in l.a
so this is why it's tough for me to get
those old guests i'm trying to get new
guests on the east coast but until then
you got uncle joey throwing heat here on
a [__] monday and wednesday this week
the first wednesday of the month
uh i love you [__] with all my
heart
[__] cincinnati bengals against the
rams and the super bowl you got
draftkings uh
that's it and that's that i love you
[__] and you're 12 days away
from valentine's day that's why manscape
is here to save the day today i love you
[__] and i'll see you next
week tip top [__] magoo
all right thank you for letting me give
you a little tattoo today of life you
know i love your [__] i'm always
thinking about you and as usual thank
you for supporting the ice cream shop
and uh cocoa weed it's [__]
tremendous and it burns tremendous with
a freeze pipe you don't even feel it
going down your throat
it's like blowing a [__] you know
anyway the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com time is money
the hassle of [__] getting in your
car and standing online at the post
office those days are over with
stance.com makes it easy
to mail and ship right from your own
house your own computer you save time
and money with stamps.com there's no
mumbo jumbo you get discounted rates on
usps ups and more like i told you in the
beginning my wife loves it i love it
we've been using it for over 10 years
stampscott.com brings you the services
of the us postal service
and ups shipping right to your computer
all you need is a computer and a
standard printer no special supplies
or equipment and within minutes you're
up and running
printing postage for any letter any
package anywhere
no traffic no lines listen to me like
uncle joey i love you stop wasting time
in the post office standing online
stamps.com has a no risk promo package
you ready four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in joey j-o-e-y that
stamps dot com
promo code joey never go to a post
office again
the joint is also brought to you by
manscape listen
it's valentine's day guys i've been
talking to you about trimming your nuts
your chest hairs your armpit hairs
listen you want your dick sucked for
valentine's day you gotta get manscaped
it's that easy it makes a more enjoyable
situation for your spouse or your
girlfriend or your boyfriend join the
four million men
worldwide who trust manscape
with my exclusive offer go to
manscape.com
and use promo code diaz d-i-a-z
for 20 off and free shipping
i'm only goofing with you guys but it's
true
it's enough is enough you got to make
yourself look [__] presentable i am a
human slot
but my hue my [__] unit looks
tremendous extreme it's trimmed it
smells fresh with all the help from
manscape whether it's the [__]
ball rejuvenator
the weed whacker the aloe vera and salt
new body wash manscape has you covered
and now on the
most romantic day of the year
manscape introduces their refined
cologne which smells [__] tremendous
now the rest of your body can smell as
good as your nut sac so you know their
products legit they're vegan cruelty
free nobody gets stabbed in the eye
there's no pigeons missing an eye and
die free your balls and your lady will
thank you but you have to get 20 off
free shipping with code diaz at
manscape.com go to manscape.com right
now
put in code diaz and get 20
off on the total [__] package
join cupid and shoot your [__] poison
arrow with manscape you dirty
[__] and here we go
that's it listen prepare yourself you've
been waiting [__] since september for
soup bowl sunday oh my god onion dip
farts
women shaking their titties and you
winning some money with the draft king
sports book the official sports
of the super bowl 56 is giving all
customers 56 to one odds that's a deal
that means you better fin you win 280
and free bets to get the party started
did you read about the guy that went won
a half a mill on the 23 bucks no you
didn't that's why i'm throwing you now
and draftking sportsbook is live in new
york slinging dick and taking out names
from the casino to sports betting and
the sports book isn't your thing yeah
it's not in your state no worries
draftkings daily fantasy football
contest are here for super bowl 56 new
customers get a free shot at winning a
million dollar top prize that's not a
[__] joke that's draftkings
download the draftking sportsbook app or
the fantasy app today and use promo code
joey you bet five dollars you win 280
and free bets who takes care of you like
uncle joey nobody with draftkings that's
promo code joey must be 21 old the
minimum age and location requirements
vary by jurisdiction see draftkings.com
book for details for full list of
requirements and state-specific
responsible gaming resources void we're
prohibited you got a gammon problem call
1-800 gambler in tennessee
1-800-889-9789 in connecticut
eight seven 888-789-7777 eight hope
get your party started with draftkings i
want to thank draftkings
manscapestamps.com i want to thank cbd
lion
i want to thank all you [__]
who had my back next last week and i
want to thank the source
better help for always helping you out
go to better help
and talk to somebody it's going to
change your life like a changed mind i
love you guys with all my heart have a
great week and i'll see you [__] up
this tip top magoo
monday morning i love you stay black be
safe blow that candle out [__]
you